let me just say that in addition to
those here at the on the stage a number
of other people in the audience were
involved in the case jonathan weiss
glass who's interviewing here today for
his law firm from san francisco was a
first-year student william broberg who
is coming in and out with his daughter
he is the husband of Lisa du gard was
involved with the Haitian resettlement
program Renee dematteo who's my special
assistant was at the time my assistant
working on the case with the students
and then there are a number of other
people in the building deeply involved
members of LSO Guido Calabresi was at
the time the Dean how do you tell this
story let me now put that question to
someone from the Yale Law School class
of nineteen ninety-two Brandt goldstein
he's a graduate of brown in yale law
school he clerked for judge Harry
Edwards of the DC Circuit he worked at
the Washington law firm of Cleary
Gottlieb he was a co-founder of an
online legal commentary journal called
RIT and then has also written for a
slate and the New York Times Magazine
Brandt want to go ahead and tell us how
this became a book thank you very much
Harold and uh hello everyone it's it's
it's great to be back here at Yale which
is the main setting for this book
storming the court and I'm pleased to be
sharing the stage with four people I've
been hounding for interviews for six
years storming the court is a true story
of Yale Law Students and human rights
lawyers including Dean Harold Koh who
challenged the US government on behalf
of Haitian refugees who were fleeing
Haiti fleeing persecution and also
specifically a group of Haitian refugees
who were not referred to in the video
you saw 300 people who had proven that
they deserved asylum in this country but
had tested positive for HIV and were
left on Guantanamo in what amounted to
America's first HIV
ancient camp surrounded by razor wire
and guard towers and under guard by a
joint task force from the United States
military how do you tell this story well
if I've done my job right what I've
written is a human rights legal thriller
the story of a group of passionate
idealists who were determined to hold
America to its highest principles and
the collision of those ideals with the
often harsh realities of the worlds of
politics and and the courts at what I
want to do is quickly kind of set up how
this happened you understand that
Jumbotron tu eres deed was ousted in a
military coup and that Haitians fled by
the thousands activists fled by the
thousands and were intercepted by US
Coast Guard cutters which what you
didn't see in the in the video is this
for the first six months after the coup
the Coast Guard cutters brought the
Haitian refugees to Guantanamo Bay a
place that we all know now for very
different reasons and on Guantanamo
federal immigration officials
interviewed each individual Haitian and
they were after one question are you a
political refugee are technically a
refugee do you have a well-founded fear
of persecution and therefore you're
allowed to come to the United States or
are you merely quote-unquote an economic
migrant and we can send you straight
back to Haiti most of the Haitians were
sent back about 25,000 of the 35,000 who
were intercepted were sent back to Haiti
about 10,000 were brought into the
United States 300 were left on
Guantanamo including a woman named devon
Pascal and this is part of the answer to
Harold's question how do you write a
book like this you focus on individual
people you're going to care about when
we see photos or images like we did up
on screen of hundreds of people we're
thinking nameless faceless refugees I
spent five years getting to know one
person a woman named devon Pascal a 28
year old mother of two children who
lived in CA Soleil I think we saw an
imager to
of that sprawling slum outside of
port-au-prince she's the wife of a
high-level political dissident and after
the coup soldiers from the Haitian
military knocked down her door beat her
in front of her children dragged her
away to a prison in downtown
port-au-prince attacked her with rifle
butts and lit cigarettes she miscarried
on the floor of the prison cell and
passed out amazingly she survived this
incident and was released and decided
that she had to flee and she was one of
the three hundred people after leaving
her children and safekeeping with her
mother she was one of the three hundred
people who ended up on Guantanamo having
tested positive for HIV and found
herself in the following situation we
would not allow her into the United
States we could not send her back to
Haiti so this was this small group and
the issue was would anyone be able to do
anything for them now I'll take you to
new haven connecticut yale law school my
classmates the class of nineteen ninety
two including Lisa dugard who is sitting
right here today they were watching this
in in the media and a number of them had
been in human rights clinic Lowenstein
clinic with Professor Co some of the
others who are interested in this had
worked for uh in the for low-income
clients in a landlord-tenant clinic and
some other clinics and they all had
different motivations but they saw what
was going on than the papers for for
some it was the story of the st. Louis
and the st. Louis was a boat that was
returned by the United States in 1939
just before World War two carrying over
900 German Jews who'd been fleeing the
Nazi regime we did not give them asylum
and many of them ended up perishing and
gas chambers for other people the
motivation was the efforts for democracy
in Haiti I certainly know that that
motivated Lisa and and and and this
group of people ultimately went to Dean
co then professor Harold Koh and
suggested to him that they file a
lawsuit
on behalf of the Haitians on Guantanamo
heralds initial reaction was that this
seemed a seeding Lee tall order while
his international human rights clinic
had dealt with them foreign dictators
and military officials who were accused
of torture they often did not show up
into court and what Java Lowenstein
clinic was often pursuing was default
judgments against the defendants this
group of students without their JD
without having passed the bar without
really having practice law except for
perhaps a year or two with clinic
experience wanted to pick a fight with
the United States Department of Justice
a litigation machine with tens of
thousands of lawyers endless resources
and a client the United States White
House that was never going to yield they
wanted to deal with a United States
Coast Guard operation in the Caribbean a
US Naval Base 1,500 miles away and the
clients they were talking about were
being held incommunicado and spoke a
language that nobody here at yale-new
one way or another Harold initially sent
Lisa who was one of the first students
to come to him away but the students
were not so easily we're not so easily
deterred over the next few days memos
began piling up in his office first one
then two then six there were law review
article xeroxed and highlighted
photocopied cases with asterisks next to
footnotes there were post-its piled on
his door and his voicemail became
crammed with messages they wouldn't
leave him alone and he continued finally
to meet with them and I I think for
Harold it was also a personal matter
because some of you may know that he is
the son of people who are effectively
political refugees from Korea his father
served as a high-level diplomat from
Korea here in the United States many
years ago and after a military coup in
Korea his father could not return his
father could not return and the Koch
family ended up living in New Haven
Connecticut and one way or another to
quote michael barr from class of
nineteen ninety two who
not here Harold and the students decided
to go over the waterfall and they filed
the case on behalf of the Haitians
initially on Guantanamo in March of 1992
and ended up before the judge who was
with us today judge sterling Johnson of
the Eastern District of New York in
Brooklyn the way that the United States
government responded should sound very
familiar to you a number of Justice
Department lawyer swept into court and
they said the plaintiffs have no legal
leg to stand on and the reason is that
the Constitution of the United States
does not apply to Guantanamo we can do
whatever we want to these people because
they have no rights on top of that the
government filed a rule 11 sanctions
motion against professor CO and Yale for
having filed a frivolous lawsuit these
people are an overall of hurt right now
they've got three days to respond to a
to a motion that was the size of a phone
book and extraordinarily I guess this is
the day before spring break began they
took a divide-and-conquer strategy and
perhaps two dozen law students poured
into professor ko's living room and they
divided in Concord they divided up all
of the work and over the next three days
night and day responded to all the
arguments by the government and judge
Johnson after having reviewed the papers
ultimately issued at ero in favor of
Yale and gave the law students and
professor Co access to Guantanamo to
meet with their clients and this is
where chapter 4 of my book begins with
Michael wish knee getting on a plane a
c-130 transport plane in the pre-dawn
darkness from a South Carolina Air Force
Base on his way to Guantanamo to meet
with his clients there and I'm going to
turn the discussion back to Harold and
over to judge Johnson about his reaction
how the case began but um I want to add
a couple comments about how it is that I
ended up writing this and I think one of
one of the themes here today
is um the passion that all of the people
on this stage here have for human rights
and perhaps the kind of passion that
you're looking for and whatever career
you ultimately chose and passion is what
drove me to write this book first the
passion of the students involved Harold
and a number of the students asked me to
work on this case and I was up to my
ears writing about the homeless in new
haven at the time and decided not to but
I was struck from the word go by what
was happening in the halls of this
school I saw Lisa I saw Mike later I saw
many other people from my class with
pale faces and dark circles under their
eyes running down the hall with huge
piles of legal research in their arms
clearly up to something of great
significance and the next day there'd be
a report about it in the New York Times
there was also the passion of Harold Koh
we all have a professor a teacher
whether it's in high school or college
or law school who lights up the room for
us who has the kind of charisma
magnetism excitement and passion for
their subject that makes you care about
it that makes you want to work hard that
makes you want to believe in that
subject and Harold was that teacher for
me when I was a first year student and
civil procedure I wanted to see the way
his passion played out in this case
particularly because I knew the
principles that were at stake the
principles that protected his own family
were at issue here but finally and most
important for me it was about the
passion of people like Yvonne Pascal I
had been thinking about writing about
this case for perhaps seven or eight
years and always knew in a way that I
wanted to become a writer most of what i
did when i was here at Yale was write
papers and avoided exams whenever I
could but the thought about writing this
case it stayed with me all during my
years of practice and when I finally
decided it was time to turn to writing
the story I had the opportunity to
interview with on early on this was a
woman who had nearly been killed for her
belief in democracy she had been
tortured because she had been churning
out pro Aristide leaflets the night
she was confronted by the Haitian
military she had spent a year on
Guantanamo unsure if she would ever see
her family again having fled and hoping
to find safe haven in the United States
only to be put in a detention camp and
it was incredibly important to me to
tell Yvonne's story it's very easy for
the President of the United States to
talk about how people are not being
persecuted in Haiti and he has access to
the media and out pores that message to
everybody it took me six years to
respond in this book with a tale of one
person to demonstrate what was happening
to help the reader identify with the
people who were fleeing for them to
understand what was at stake personally
it's now six years later the book is
done and it's my hope that when people
read this they'll realize that when
people flee from a place like Haiti and
they're fleeing political persecution
it's not just a nameless faceless group
of individuals that we can simply push
back and declare this isn't happening
that isn't happening we needn't worry
about it it's not our problem and so on
and so forth Avon Pascal is a real
individual ave on Pascal is a person we
should care about in human rights
lawyers like the people were sitting
here today are the people who have to
stand up and fight and save people like
a lawn Pascal thanks Brad I'm glad we
didn't hear your description of the
challenges before we started the suit or
I think we never would have done
sterling Johnson jr. grew up in the
bedford-stuyvesant section of Brooklyn
he attended New York City public schools
and graduated from boys high he joined
the Marine Corps and spent part of that
time on Guantanamo and on his discharge
he joined the new york city police
department became a police officer was
promoted to detective and then to
sergeant during that time he
went to Brooklyn College he got his
bachelor's degree while working
full-time at night as a detective he
went to law school he earned a law
degree from Brooklyn Law School and
became a federal prosecutor by 1975 he
had become the special narcotics
prosecutor for New York City where he
had jurisdiction of felony narcotics
offenses in all five boroughs and then
in 1991 was appointed 92 was appointed
to the federal district court for the
eastern district of new york he had been
on the bench for a very short period of
time when a case came to him through the
wheel which is called haitian centers
council versus mcnairy and the group of
us here walked into his courtroom in
march of 1992 the only reason we were
there that day was for two reasons one
because of a spring break and so we had
to get the suit filed before his classes
started again and secondly because we
had tried to get the case onto the
discretionary docket of the Eastern
District and we were thrown out and sent
to the wheel and so we came in and we
met judge Johnson and judge you can take
the story from there good morning I read
the book and it is so well written I
gave it to my wife and my wife said to
me why did you give me this damn book I
can't put it down in the book there is
civil procedure this history there's
race this tension between the executive
and the judiciary there's everything and
it's written so that the average person
can understand it it is a well-written
book from my perspective I saw the trees
the book for me showed me the forest let
me begin with my background as you can
understand that I have
a background that steeped in law and law
enforcement I was a marine and i served
in Guantanamo and I is also a police
officer the important thing about those
two positions that I had as a police
officer it taught me how to make a
decision and I was surprised how many
people cannot make a decision I can make
a decision I might be wrong but I'll
learn from it and when I am reverse and
I am reverse I said it is my privilege
to have been reversed by the circuit or
the Supreme Court and the other thing
the Marine Corps taught me was
disciplined if you have discipline and
this is for you young people you can
walk on water and sometimes you don't
even need the water now I am a Democrat
and I wasn't a closet Democrat i was out
there in the open and i got a call from
the president 41 say i'm gonna send your
name to the senate for confirmation I
breeze through here I am less than six
months on the job and I find out that
Yale Law Students I read in a book had
wanted to get judge Weinstein a rinone
constitutional scholar who was a very
nice man and I hate labels but he's been
labeled liberal he was in the hospital
they couldn't get him they went to
another very nice man
judge Nickerson and the government
complained and they said that they were
judge shopping and he says that's right
put it in the wheel and lo and behold
they got judge sterling Johnson and I
was so new they want to know who is he
and the government had some experience
with me and one of the attorneys had a
very interesting choice and I think for
that reason when I had first come to the
court I was wanted at nine o'clock 930
the chief judge says you have a trial I
hadn't tried a case in 25 years but id
on my robes I looked scholarly ascended
the bench and peered down at the lawyers
and I ask what type of case is this and
the prosecutor says narcotics and I said
was it smoke dope blow or crack the
prosecutor look at defense counsel
defense counselor looked at the
prosecutor dating what the hell I was
talking about the defendant looked at me
didn't bad I he knew what i was talking
about
he pled guilty so when the prosecutor
said a very interesting choice now I
knew what he meant so the law students
come before me and they make their
arguments and I'm I scheduled it for a
hearing and I recall that I asked a
couple of real pointed questions because
the fact situation was terrible as far
as the government was concerned and the
government said that they wanted a
continuance because they were going to
bring the Solicitor General end to argue
this case in front of me but it was not
what the lawyer said but it was how he
said it it was almost as if there was a
slim inul message and I wanted to let
him know that I got his message and I
was going to send him a message and it
wasn't sold subliminal I said to him you
can bring the Solicitor General or
anybody else you want I will not be
intimidated I'm from bed-stuy the
Solicitor General at that time was Ken
Stahl so the case was so important to
the administration because the Solicitor
General as you know or you will know
that Solicitor General only all use
cases in the US Supreme Court but he
came down to Mike warden he was arguing
his case and I had asked him
some cases and I was trying to make this
point they the government said that
because the Haitians at that time were
being taken to Guantanamo Bay that
Guantanamo Bay was not a u.s. territory
they had no right and I said assuming
without conceding that the government
officials were arbitrary capricious and
even cruel could the Haitians come to
federal court for relief because they
were being held by American authorities
the lawyer and I don't remember who it
was said no well it got so quiet at you
here at pissing in cotton from a
thousand yards and I put that away and
then the fun began I eventually gave a
preliminary injunction because there was
irreparable harm and I think there was a
chance of success on the merit merits
not withstanding there was an Eleventh
Circuit case similar to the one that the
a law students were filing that went in
the opposite direction went up to what
the Supreme Court you said five times
and Court of Appeals how many times
seven times and things I guess worked
out eventually as I understand it that
when I eventually said to the government
that you're going to release these
people from Guantanamo Bay I don't care
where you send him as long as you don't
send them back to Haiti there were
repercussions to this well let me
backtrack what happened was
Clinton decided he was not going to
appeal my decision to the Supreme Court
and that ruling is the ruling of the
case but I got letters from anonymous
citizens hooray for sickle-cell anemia
the white man's hope I got a check to
say five dollar check put these rubber
gloves on so you can shake hands with
these hiv-positive Haitians when they
come to the United States I was accused
of meaning al [ __ ] justice but I did
what I had to do and I would do it all
over again thank you Lisa du Gard is a
member of the Yale Law School class of
nineteen ninety-two she grew up in
Washington state she attended college at
age 12 she went to graduate school at
Cornell at age 17 we remember
celebrating her birthday and when she
was i did 25 and we realized that she
had been arrested 25 times and had on
her 25th birthday at yale law school she
was involved in a series of activities
and then ultimately became involved with
a human rights clinic and she was one of
the students who worked on the case from
the first day to the last day part of
that time was spent as a fellow at the
aclu national legal department she went
on to become legal director of the
Coalition for the homeless director of
the urban justice center organizing
project and in 1996 she became a public
defender in seattle washington at the
defender Association where she now
supervises the racial disparity project
in the misdemeanor division at the
defender Association she's also the
mother of Lucy who's out there and the
wife of bill burr
Berg who she met while working on the
Haitian case I should also mention that
Lisa received a prestigious federal
clerkship and then finally decided after
working on the case that she would
prefer to not do that and do what you
did instead Lisa my Herald talked about
my starting a lot of schools um he
didn't mention that I didn't have a very
good record at finishing degrees and so
it did take me I think his brand said a
few years after i left Yale Law School
in 1992 to get my degree my partner
William basically refused to let me come
out of the apartment until I finished a
few incomplete papers and he entered
into some alliance with xena Schaefer
who was the registrar and may still be
the Registrar here to make sure I got my
degree when I was asked to come here
Renee DeMatteo asked whether I was in
the class of 92 or 95 and I really don't
know the answer to that question I'm
supposed to take you from the point at
which the preliminary injunction was
issued through the trial and really
focusing on the Guantanamo case there's
a whole second aspect of the case that
Mike is going to talk about I'll do that
very quickly and then try to share a few
lessons when Harold left off judge
Johnson had issued a temporary
restraining order and ordered that we
could go to Guantanamo to conduct
discovery in preparation for a
preliminary injunction hearing that
would be just a short time off we really
had a matter of days to conduct
discovery compilat briefed every issue
and returned to judge Johnson and asked
for a preliminary injunction that would
last through trial and so Mike went to
Guantanamo with another student Sarah
Cleveland and one of the lawyers on the
case Robert Rubin to meet our clients
and investigate the conditions in the
camp other students went literally all
over the country to to the District of
Columbia to Miami to conduct depositions
review documents and some
stayed here to compile what was pouring
back in other other students went to
Miami to interview other refugees who
had been through Guantanamo to talk
about their experiences there so from
points all around the country and from
Guantanamo information started pouring
back into Yale and at the time it's hard
to imagine now but the legal services
clinics used to be a very dingy affair
we were upstairs like on the fourth
floor and third floor fourth floor and
we were operating out of and there was
no internet I think somebody was talking
about how there was some electronic way
to get a brief from New Haven to New
York but we couldn't figure it out so we
were you know schlepping things down
physically on discs on on metro-north we
were working upstairs and rape Russia
one of the students who's not here today
but who went discusses in the book was
running the whole show making sure that
Harold and I and others gave up our
materials in time to get everything
assimilated into a brief that could be
submitted ray famously one time met a
deadline this is an important lesson
from the case met a midnight deadline to
fax a brief and we were nowhere near
done I mean he could not physically pull
the disk from Harold or for me so he
realized that we had a really extensive
appendix of about 200 pages and he
realized he could fax it backwards meet
the med that midnight deadline and we
could have a couple extra hours to work
on the brief so he got that in the fax
machine and then held up the phone and
played i'm too sexy for the US attorney
with his shirt off apparent
remember that party in any event that
the brief got filed and judge Johnson
did did eventually grant the preliminary
injunction obviously there are a lot of
details that I'm leaving out here and
the injunction essentially said that we
would have access to our clients and
that they could not be repatriated to
Haiti without having the opportunity to
have lawyers if the if the Justice
Department or if the US government
wanted to process them further judge
Johnson wasn't ordering anybody to come
into the United States and he wasn't
even ordering well he wasn't ordering
the dismantling of the camp at
Guantanamo but he was saying you could
not process people further without
minimal due process protections and that
meant that essentially the government
could freeze people in place and
Guantanamo and that yet they were
unwilling to do that and they asked
Johnson says stay his order pending
appeal arguing that he was certain to be
reversed he declined to stay the order
they went to the Second Circuit asked
Second Circuit to stay the order the
Second Circuit also declined to stay it
and so the government then turned to the
Supreme Court and in a really crushing
moment for us the Supreme Court voted to
stay judge Johnson's order pending
appeal which had been expedited we were
talking about a matter of a couple of
weeks when the government would not have
been able to operate the camp on
Guantanamo exactly as they wished by the
pool and the vote was 524 and
nonetheless what that meant was that
immediately the Justice Department could
commence i ns at the time used to be
called the immigration and national
national ization naturalization service
now ice could start re interviewing
people without lawyers on guantanamo we
had after much discussion focused on
this issue of access to lawyers because
it seemed like a small procedural
challenge to what was going on it wasn't
ordering anybody into the country it
wasn't really going after the entire
scheme just said you know if you're
going to process people they need this
minimal procedural protection our
clients who with whom we were not
really having direct communication
nonetheless understood that this was one
of the devices or one of the claims in
the case and so when the Supreme Court
granted the stay and processing began
immediately immediately and they were
ready to go and they they took folks and
started taking them in to be interviewed
a large group almost a hundred including
some of the camp leaders some of the
most self-confident and brave people in
the camp refused to subject themselves
to or be subjected to interviews without
lawyers and when they did that they were
summarily repatriated to Haiti they were
marched onto a Coast Guard Cutter we got
frantic calls from some other brave
people this time working for the United
States on Guantanamo saying that this
was happening and could we do something
to stop it one of the most gripping and
wrenching times for all of us on the
case was when we learned that this was
happening we knew that folks were taking
literally the legal claims that we had
articulated on their behalf this thing
about lawyers and we're most likely
waiting for us to do something to stop
their repatriation we spent a really
horrible day and night wrestling with
what we could do whether we could do
anything legally and ultimately decided
that that we couldn't and those folks
were repatriated we were somewhat
miraculously able to reach one of the
leaders after he returned to haiti and
had and mike actually had very extensive
communication with him for a period of
time after that and helped him to escape
to the Dominican Republic there was then
essentially you know everybody who was
everybody who was at the camp got
processed one way or the other either
they were reinterview dealt with out
lawyers and found not to not to reach
the second standard a fear of
persecution and could be repatriated or
they were we interviewed found to meet
this standard
and then what they just remain there in
this limbo in Guantanamo there was a
lull of some time during the well and I
should say that the Second Circuit
ultimately affirmed judge Johnson on the
merits in May but really the damage had
been done and and our clients had been
forced to make that that fundamental
choice of whether to cooperate or not
the government in the in the late summer
early fall made and made some overtures
to settle the litigation and this was
still under the Bush administration and
made us an offer essentially to give us
everything we had seemed to be asking
for these procedural rights you can have
lawyers for any processing the problem
when will do Asylum type interviews at
Guantanamo the problem is that they at
this point we were all clear that
everybody remaining at the camp either
had been had been tested and found to
either be HIV positive or was a relative
of somebody who is HIV positive
virtually everyone at the camp and the
government was still maintaining this
position that Haitians who were outside
the country in US custody with HIV would
not be allowed to come in so the the
offer was you can go through all this
processing but if you succeed and you
qualify for asylum then what nothing you
still it's indefinitely you would remain
at Guantanamo we didn't necessarily
think much of this offer but did
recognize the unique opportunity that
was afforded this because ethically we
we couldn't reject that offer ourselves
we as you know needed to communicate it
to our clients and this was something we
had not been able to do directly since
Mike's brief trip months before so we
went on a venture to the court ordered
that we be allowed to go to Guantanamo
to order and the government agreed that
we'd be allowed to go to Guantanamo to
communicate the offer to the clients so
after a gap of months with only the most
indirect communication Harold Michael
Ratner my
self 3 law students 3 haitian
interpreters and gorilla explorers and
and a doctor arrived at guantanamo and
marched into the big hangar there where
the clients had been convened to meet
with us this was really a remarkable a
remarkable exchange a remarkable meeting
it's hard to put into words how the the
the odd situation of having had your
entire life and that of all these other
people completely transformed by the
representation of individuals who don't
even know that you exist as a person I
mean they have no idea then idea who I
was that only the vaguest idea who these
people were who claimed to be
representing them and were representing
them and and we I mean we were they were
very much in our power if you will
accept that we we hadn't succeeded in
doing very much for them at that point
they had very little control over what
if any control over what we were doing
on their behalf and the next three days
was an exercise in breaking down those
barriers and forging more of a real
partnership in advancing their cause in
their case one of the abiding lessons
that I draw from this litigation is the
limited value of what often passes as
professionalism in legal advocacy and I
learned that really at Guantanamo in two
different ways one Harold sort of
appreciating the the polarity in our
position and the distance between us
immediately attempted to break that down
with with our clients by talking about
his own family's refugee experience and
why it was that he cared about this many
of you will if you go on to be
litigators will be told that you're not
especially if you go on to be public
defenders or work in legal services will
be urged by your colleagues not to share
personal details of your life or your
life experience or your motivation with
your clients there needs to be you know
you need to be at arm's length etc
ara I don't believe that I don't believe
it makes for an effective
attorney-client relationship and
particularly not with extremely with
clients who are at an extreme
disadvantage with you and the power
relationship and so Harold's offering of
his own family's personal experience was
terribly important in transcending that
similarly I had an experience where I
was being grilled by clients in a small
group I was working with who said you
guys don't really care about us you're
just doing this to get famous or rich
and I thought I have the perfect answer
to that was like well we're getting
neither I don't know about famous but
we're certainly not getting rich we're
doing this for free and then they said
aha we knew you couldn't be a very good
lawyer because you can't you doing this
only because no one else will pay you to
do to do any work and it became very
there's also a sleep deprivation factor
here but it began to seem to me that it
would be impossible to bridge this
divide and I was very sad about that
because of course we were working very
hard on their behalf and I started to
cry and then I thought this is the worst
I mean on top of the fact that we're we
don't really care and we're and nobody
will pay us now they have lawyers who
are very young female and I'm are crying
this is not going to engender confidence
and I got up and left the room to try to
compose myself an older woman came out
tapped me on the shoulder and said one
of the very few English words that she
knew which was come come brought me back
in and had someone interpret that they
had decided that it probably we were
trustworthy after all because if I
hadn't actually cared this what they had
said would not have hurt me and I would
not have cried and so ironically this
crying this absolute breakdown and
professionalism was for that group and
for me the opportunity to forge a real
relationship of trust which proved to be
very very important in the case okay so
we went to Guantanamo and had kind of a
moment of truth with our clients where
we were talking about you know Bill
Clinton was running for president he had
promised to both end the HIV exclusion
and and the repatriation of Haitian
refugees and that seemed very promising
to us the clients were quite skeptical
of political promises i would say i'm
not completely disregarding this but
quite skeptical and wanted to know kind
of what the back-up plan was and we had
not we did not have a clearly defined
answer at that time the law was not
great for us to make a slight
understatement on the merits on whether
or not you could detain non-citizens
outside the country indefinitely under
less than wonderful conditions and there
was no case there was there was no place
that case that clearly said you couldn't
do that and so in terms of the ultimate
legal answer what were we going to do we
didn't have a clear response for the
clients but we took that dilemma back I
mean we had done some research that
suggested that possibly there was an
argument to be made and another abiding
lesson of this case for me is that
there's really no such thing as bad law
if you if you read bad cases for your
position bad cases carefully there's
always something that the court says you
know and what we're not saying that you
could actually torture people outside
the country in exclusive US custody but
that is not this case and so you there's
always some like hypothetical scenario
that's so bad that the court would take
action or the court would recognize a
cause of action it's just not this case
so our challenge was to make our case
that that thing that was worse that was
out there that had never yet been
precluded by US courts but could but
could be precluded now and we began to
think about how to do that ultimately
that is what what the trial in the case
ended up being about and when we left
wanton mo you and came and came back
rejecting the offer the plan was
essentially wait for Clinton to get
elected do an enormous amount of
political work to ensure that those
promises were kept and when they were
not kept it was not for want of an
extraordinary political mobilization to
try to make those promises a reality
and then there was kind of a bet the
back-up plan was prepare for trial
that's probably not really going to
happen as you all know and saw the
Clinton promises both about the HIV
exclusion and about the repatriation of
Haitians were not kept and two things
then ensued one we had to we had to go
to trial and our clients felt an immense
degree of betrayal about Clinton and
then decided that they had to take
matters into their own hands and you've
probably read recently about a current
hunger strike among detainees at
Guantanamo the antecedent of that is
that our clients went on hunger strike
led by Yvonne Pascal and really played
and imagined and they were so isolated
ultimately we got reporters be to be
able to go to the base but mostly
they're there was nobody there except
the military and a few chaplains and
interpreters they were I mean what could
they do to take some power back about
their own future they'd been told they
had a deadly disease and they were going
to die and the US government was talking
about how they were going to die at the
camp and so what did it really matter
where they were they not all believe not
everybody believed they were HIV
positive but they were afraid it was
true what could they do to take back
some power and the hunger strike was
pretty much the weapon of last resort it
had a tremendous impact on our work
number one it gave it even more urgency
there was a sense that this was life or
death and that we had to find a way
through law through street activism
through public policy advocacy through
media work we had to find a way to shut
that camp down this was life or death
for 300 people and number two it gave
the media and activists HIV and AIDS
activists Haitian activists around the
country a focal point to rally around
and to devote a tremendous amount of
resources and time themselves around
and so the third abiding lessons from
the case is that the critical nature of
forging a working partnership between
lawyers and advocates on the one hand
and clients particularly very
dispossessed clients on the other and
and to it's important for the lawyers to
empower the clients and it's very
critical for the lawyers to be empowered
by the clients and to be to take the
information the truth and the tools that
clients will will offer and integrate
those into the advocacy strategy they
went on hunger strike Jesse Jackson went
to Guantanamo and persuaded most of the
refugees that the world was watching and
that they had succeeded and that was
really true and that they could begin to
eat again and they mostly did begin to
eat again we went to trial at this point
the case which had started out being
about nothing really about HIV it was
all about refugees and and refugee
policy very much ended up being about
hiv/aids and revolved around the the
kind of transforming definition of aids
that had been expanded by the work of a
number of activists and with whom we
were working in activist doctors to
include medical conditions that are
often suffered by women and so that most
of the folks on Guantanamo could
eventually be categorized as suffering
from AIDS which meant that they could
not receive adequate medical care on the
base which meant that we had a very
compelling claim that that wasn't lawful
for to detain them there anymore judge
Johnson ordered that they had to be
released from Guantanamo they could not
be repatriated to Haiti and essentially
that was it that the government did not
have the power to keep them there and
did not have the power to take them back
to Haiti they could be taken anywhere
else but they were actually brought here
because of the phenomenal work of
activist social workers and
and homeless advocates including my
partner William who found a way to bring
folks into and lots of work by Mike who
all found a way to bring refugees into
New York City boston and miami and other
US cities in a way that where the world
did not end they were well-integrated
into the social service networks that
existed in those cities and and and and
it was not the end of the world a
surprising lesson I think for some on
the other side to learn I will and there
and turn it over to Mike let me say that
Mike wish he is a native of Boston he
went to Yale College Yale Law School in
the in-between he taught in china in the
yale and china association at yale law
school he was involved with the lso
clinic and then got involved with this
case he was in this case a witness and a
lawyer as well as a resettlement person
Mike was famous whenever we had to bring
in another refugee he would say quoting
his hero dennis eckersley just give me
the rock then afterwards he went to work
at brooklyn legal aid he served as a law
clerk for Lisa rockin on the District of
New Jersey in the Third Circuit as a law
clerk at the Supreme Court to just as
Harry Blackmun and Steve Breyer became a
Skadden fellow at the ACLU immigrants
rights project working with lawyers he
first met on this cake and the Haitian
case and then joined the clinical
faculty at NYU Law School where he's
continued to do immigrants rights and
civil legal services work last year he
was a visiting professor at Yale Law
School and we welcome them back Thank
You Harold it's uh it's actually
terrific to be i'm not sure i've been in
this room since i SAT here for jonathan
Spence's lecture like 20 years ago but
it's great to see everybody well my
assignment I have two assignments really
one is to carry forward the other part
of the case which doesn't turn out as
well as the part Lisa got to talk about
the
Arthur went up to the Supreme Court and
secondly to talk a little bit about the
resettlement into what became of people
and I'll share a couple of observations
also so first the Supreme Court piece of
it the case essentially became two parts
when in may of 92 just a few days after
Lisa and her classmates graduated there
all year ahead of me I was kind of a
class of 92 wannabe for most of my law
school career President Bush's he saw
announced that he was changing the
policy instead of bringing people to
Guantanamo was simply going to summarily
return everybody stopped at sea to Haiti
to their persecutors in many cases
without any refugee screening and so
people literally took off their robes
the graduation I imagine did you wear a
robe did you walk that yeah okay he's a
fraud he was still five or so pages a
paper short of graduation but anyhow
they all took off their robes and I was
already back in New York I think of the
ACLU for the summer but went back in
front of judge Johnson for a second TR 0
to try to stop the summary return judge
Johnson ultimately denied that
application condemning the government
for his behavior but holding that he was
bound by Circuit precedent to hold it it
was permit was lawful and as the judge
has sometimes pointed out to me he was
affirmed in every respect ultimately in
both pieces of the case we appealed to
the Second Circuit which reversed judge
Johnson and in July of 92 in joined the
Coast Guard from stopping and summarily
returning everybody to Guantanamo and I
remember it very vividly because it was
I think the day of the bar exam that we
got the order or maybe the next day and
so we all kind of rallied at simpson
thacher the law firm that was in the
case and people like ray brassicae
mumbling out of the bar exam you know
not having slept for a month to work on
the state papers because we knew this
would be back in the Supreme Court
unfortunately Supreme Court
the case and as you know eventually
reversed the Second Circuit affirming
judge Johnson and proving his his
judicial instincts correct unfortunately
in that case but a few words about the
the Supreme Court effort that this
became the second part there was the
case going to trial about people who
were still stuck at Guantanamo solely
because they were hiv-positive or had
AIDS or a family member did some people
did not have the disease and those who
were working on a Supreme Court case
which became a mammoth effort I actually
was on the sort of trial team I spent
that fall in New York as Harold said we
didn't all attend too many classes in
fact in that semester I took classes at
the law school only that met between two
and six on Thursdays that was my
criteria for class selection this
semester and I lived with my girlfriend
now my wife in New York the other six
and a half days a week but the team back
in New Haven took the lead on the
supreme court case and wrote opposition
to the government serve position the
merits briefs and then played a very
substantial role in guiding does little
I mean I couldn't count them last night
but a you know a dozen or so amicus
briefs presenting a range of views from
all sorts of important perspectives on
the government practices this was an
enormous effort because the Supreme
Court had expedited briefing through the
fall and that sort of required and just
a tremendously grinding pace here in New
York I sorry here in New Haven I later
clerked for justice Blackmun and briar
and so had an opportunity to review
justice Blackmun's personal case file
from the cases because Harold was then
conducting an oral history of Justice
Blackmun and my job was to kind of help
justice Blackmun remember the cases by
helping him review these files it's all
they're all in the library of congress
now so i reveal no secrets when I share
a little bit from what happened at the
court but come argument we knew we it
would be difficult of course the Supreme
Court had stayed the Second Circuit 722
only black men and Stevens have
dissented
we knew simply on the face of it not to
mention the difficulty of legal
arguments that it could be hard indeed
it was argument was difficult it's
recounted and very suspenseful account
in the book with Harold arguing for us
against murine Mahoney from the
Solicitor General's Office I won't go
into the legal details but essentially
we pressed a claim that both the
immigration statute and a treaty which
the statute incorporated and implemented
forbade the US government from returning
people to their persecutors without any
inquiry into whether they were refugees
but of course this meant literally we
were trying to turn ships around at sea
and the court seemed reluctant to do
that when the president was describing
this is a grave foreign policy crisis
both Republican and Democratic president
seemingly making it a nonpartisan issue
at conference the justices met soon
after the argument and at conference all
but justice Blackmun were pretty clear
that they wanted to reverse the Second
Circuit they disagreed on the ground
some preferred a procedural ground
called collateral estoppel most wanted
to reach the merits as Harold had all
along predicted they would justice
Stevens drafted an opinion and the only
significant debate about the opinion of
Justice Blackmun's the lone dissenter
came from Justice Scalia and I want to
read you just a word or two Justice
Scalia wrote to justice Stevens
objecting to some of the language in his
draft opinion in particular the
reference to Eris deed as the first
democratically elected president of
haiti without happen to be true so
Scalia couldn't object that it was false
but he was concerned and he wrote to
Stevens 20 years from now when it turns
out he was Fidel Castro with a Roman
collar it may look strange in our
opinion he was he was concerned that the
court might somehow be embracing era
steed he also objected to Stevens
acknowledgment in passing of the moral
weight of the Haitians argument Scalia
wrote from I taste that comes too close
to acknowledging that it is
morally wrong to return these refugees
to Haiti which I do not believe finally
he asked justice Stevens to reduce his
quotations from Judge Johnson's opinion
which had been very critical of the
government and the Stevens draft
reproduced some of Judge Johnson's
criticisms and Scalia asked Stevens to
cut judge Johnson's words out of the
final opinion well you read the opinion
you'll see that Stevens did trim back
the quote the words of Judge Johnson but
he kept in the other references well the
case came down in in June i do remember
a few days before the case came down
that Harold told me he'd had a dream
which is also related in the book that
we had 19 nothing and he kind of went
through in his dream we got Scalia on
the plain language and Thomas follow
Scalia they don't get Blackmun on the
values of you know down the line how it
had come out nine to nothing and I guess
this is you know sort of the Pete Rose
rule why you don't bet on your own cases
but didn't it didn't really turn out
that way but it was quite an education I
you know I have to say I never been to
the Supreme Court I wasn't in a small
group some of you probably already been
or will go I hadn't been in a small
group that went Brandt says in the book
that Joe tringali who is lead trial
counsel a partner at simpson and i were
too busy getting ready for trial to go
to the court argument that's not quite
true the if you read the alumni magazine
see a photograph on the courthouse steps
and you'll see me and Joe in there but
the NYU president john sexton sometimes
says when he's found to be slightly an
error the truth is not captured only by
the facts
truth was that Joe and I and Lisa and
others were mostly involved in the trial
work and Harold and many of the other
students who were still here in New
Haven were the ones who were responsible
primarily for the briefing and the
preparation for argument the moving the
coordination of all these amicus briefs
in the Supreme Court case ok a few words
about the other assignment which is more
positive as has been mentioned it felt
to me to become involved in resettlement
operation but I want to say a word or
two about how that happened because it's
one of the lessons I draw from the case
I was not part of the original group as
i said i was a want to be with this
crowd and did not formulate the original
legal theories was pulled in later when
they needed some warm bodies and in fact
was on the very first trip to guantanamo
not because i had sort of earned that
opportunity but because i wasn't useful
people like Lisa had to stay back here
and write the different injunction
briefs or go to Miami and take a
deposition because I had a clue they
developed legal theories they knew the
case I was a warm body who could go to
Guantanamo but that for me very much
grounded me and the personal experiences
and lives I was fortunate in that sense
that from almost my first hours in the
case I had a live clients that I felt
responsible to I was at an lso rat I had
done a bunch of LSO clinics and was used
to working closely with clients in
person and is probably my second or
third day on the case when we landed at
Guantanamo and I came to meet my clients
and resolved then to myself that I
simply would not rest and would do
everything in my power to see them clear
of this prison they were in solely we
learned on that trip because they had
HIV so in the summer of 92 when I was at
the ACLU back in New York and through
the fall I wanted to better connect our
lawsuit to the Haitian community in New
York which after the community Miami is
the second-largest Haitian community in
the country and began reaching out to
Haitian organizations in Brooklyn where
I was living many of them were intensely
political and filled
with longtime political activists who
fled Haiti to try to share with them
what we were learning about Guantanamo
and talked to them about local advocacy
and media work and ways to do public
education that might fit with some of
their work I did the same with AIDS
activists this these were it was a
different day act up was one of the most
formidable groups in the country I
remember going to an act up meeting to
report on Guantanamo and ask for help
and there were probably a hundred people
you know people hanging out the windows
and so jammed full of energy but partly
for me to this was because I had been
skeptical of lie didn't come to law
school to practice law I didn't have
lawyers in my family I didn't really
think law in the courts mattered very
much to social justice and the lives of
most people this case convinced me that
it can but I came in thinking that
social justice comes from people from
the ground up from consciousness
changing from people as a collective
deciding that they wanted their
government to behave differently and I
came out of the case thinking actually
need both that the courts can articulate
important principles that give crucial
support to popular struggles but without
the popular struggle there's nothing to
carry out of the courtroom and input
into practice so for me part of this was
I felt we had to win in the courtroom
and we had to win outside the courtroom
and that that required public education
and activism and just getting out there
on the street so I spent a lot of time
doing that through the summer around
Labor Day that year in 92 we got a
surprising call from the government this
is still the bush administration from
Paul Cappuccio who is deputy assistant
attorney general some very senior
position a very conservative guy saying
we have a guy who's sick and we're going
to let him off his name is rigo melon
net and we're going to bring him to the
bethesda naval hospital in washington DC
because he has an eye condition that we
can't treat on guantanamo essentially we
want to let you know that will bring one
of your clients in and he was detained
for a long time
I NS facility in New York while we press
the government to release him to the
care of his brother who lived in New
York City and his brother's wife who was
a nurse who could care for him but this
was the first of what became a trickle
in that a bit more of a stream of calls
from the government saying so-and-so is
so ill our facilities are inadequate we
want to let them out at first the
government wanted to detain people but
eventually they came to trust us that we
could resettle people at no expense to
the government and keep it out of the
newspapers it wouldn't become an
embarrassment to the Bush administration
and give people to care that couldn't
get at Guantanamo from their family and
friends and doctors and so on and
through the fall the same network of
organizations that I had reached out two
days activists Haitian community groups
became the group's often that took the
lead in resettling individuals and
connecting them with appropriate
services in the community and bro who
has been drifting around with Lucy
quickly kind of took of the lead in that
effort through the fall that continued
by the time judge Johnson issued an
interim order in the spring ordering out
those who had full-blown AIDS I think we
resettled 35 or 40 people at no expense
to the government who the government had
let out one by one but in a sense the
service effort in the advocacy effort
came to support one each one another as
we did more service that brought in more
advocates people who spoke out locally
and eventually nationally we did
top-down activism from Jesse Jackson to
as much as winning a case was a
highlight for me I would have to confess
that among the highlights was getting
too brief Susan Sarandon to go on
Arsenio Hall and talk about the Haitians
which happened at sometime in the spring
we were doing sort of top-down like
celebrity advocacy with Jonathan Demme
me it's in zanadon people like that but
also a lot of bottom-up grassroots
activity that laid the crucial
groundwork for the resettlement effort
which enabled us to say to the
government at the crucial moment when
they said well we're think of letting
people out but you know how many months
do you need to prepare
and at that moment other refugee
resettlement agencies mostly religious
based organizations formed after world
war two who had refused all my efforts
to bring their expertise to bear on our
quiet resettlement when it became a
public resettlement when judge Johnson
ordered people in suddenly the refugee
resettlement agencies went to the
government have said we'll do this will
charge twelve hundred dollars per person
sort of an administrative fee to the
government for the resettlement and we
needed several months to prepare this is
a very complicated population with HIV
and and so forth and we were able to say
to the government will do it for free
tomorrow you put them all on a plane
tomorrow we won't ask for a penny and
we'll take care of it because look we've
already resettled 35 or 40 people we
actually had to negotiate at the agency
said no no this is we need this money we
need these bounties and we had to
negotiate with the agencies in the end
we allowed them to resettle people with
family members which really means no
more than meeting some of the airport
and being sure they're with the right
family member and I was primarily people
and who had family in South Florida and
everybody who didn't have a family
member the harder cases would come to
New York at no charge and we would
handle them up here well for me
personally this effort sort of began in
the fall of 92 got very busy in the
spring of 93 after trial but continued i
went to the legal aid society after i
graduated in brooklyn and have the
opportunity to continue representing my
clients some of whom had benefits
problems some of whom soon faced
eviction proceedings all of whom needed
asylum representation and so it was
fortunate to be able to kind of stay in
contact and working directly with my
clients for a long time there was also a
Dominican Republic resettlement effort
which I won't go into as has been
alluded to there were a group of people
including most of the people I had met
the first time I went down to Guantanamo
who refused to be processed further
without lawyers who then were sent back
to port-au-prince some of whom got in
touch with us while in hiding in Haiti
and
I then worked with and a couple others
worked with to find safe passage and to
resettle bent in the Dominican Republic
but that's a different story I shouldn't
take the time on that so just to close
with a couple of reflections for me this
as I said was the case that proved law
did matter and that there is a real
power even in litigation as resource
intensive and as hopeless as it seemed
you know we're looking down the barrel
of a second term for the bush
administration a new Supreme Court but
when we were sitting here we were in
year 11 or 12 Republican judicial
appointments and we many of us thought
well we've had eight years of Reagan
appointments now we've got four years of
bush appointments what's the point of
even going to court you know all will
get is people like Joe Johnson at the
time I was naive right all i saw was did
the president who appointed the judge
but it seemed pointless to focus social
justice activism in the courts for me
this case changed that and show me that
there is a power that a single lawyer
with a piece of paper walks into the
federal courthouse or the state
courthouse and the government has to
answer they can answer with rule 11
motions they can hence her with all
sorts of bravado about this lists are
general but they have to answer they
have to be publicly accountable for
their behavior and that's a power that
only lawyers really have and pro se
litigants just by showing up and paying
your hundred and ten dollar filing fee
they have to speak to you but it also
confirmed for me that winning in court
is not enough to me we want to great
victories one was after trial but had
the government appealed I don't doubt
that we would have won in the Second
Circuit and lost in the Supreme Court
and the reason that people came out and
some are still here today is because we
of our second victory which was the
Clinton administration saying we are not
going to appeal we're going to honor the
order and then we'll think about an
appeal later have we not I believe had
we not been involved in all the media
work the exhausting local advocacy
the efforts to tell our story to the
world the hunger strike by our
classmates right out here at the table
they set off a chain reaction of hunger
strikes by law students around the
country have we not decided to engage
the public debate rather than rest on
our legal papers I don't think the
Clinton administration would have felt
the pressure it did to decide to forego
it's clear appeal rights and probably
victory so to me the the case is a whole
it teaches that lesson finally it
teaches a couple things at a personal
level about how one spends one time for
me it commits me you have to follow your
passion and I would encourage everyone
in this room if there's something that
you're passionate about that pisses you
off that makes you proud that engages
you put your time into that work and try
to find yourself in a place where you
can do that you may be at a law firm and
you've only got a little bit of time for
pro bono work spend it wisely you may be
fortunate enough to be clinical law
professor and have the autonomy to
choose every case you want to do every
moment pick wisely secondly have the
courage to stand up this was a lesson
that I learned personally from Harold
who I remembered only by reading the
book was only 36 years old when this
happened a professor a lawyer who never
stood up in court with the judge who'd
never had a TR 0 before and somehow this
was the result 36 to you is still seems
old but to me that is behind me already
thirty-six-year-old years old and
standing up have the courage of your
convictions and finally do it with
friends because if you can't raise hell
with your friends you know at some level
why bother for me I'm proud to have been
part of this collective effort I look
back at the book and I think wow it was
really a time where people I truly loved
and respected and all came together and
that's sustained all of us throughout so
find something you care about do it with
friends and stand up I'll leave it at
that you've been patient just let me
summarize some lessons I think 44
the students here first I think this is
an important moment for Yale Law School
more than a hundred students worked on
the case more than a dozen professors
signed the briefs dozens of yale law
school alumni were involved in the
litigation and the public relations
effort and the political effort and at
the end of the day it was the commitment
of Yale Law School that made the
difference the Dean of Yale Law School
opened the pocketbook of the of the law
school to pay out more than 300,000
dollars in legal costs which fortunately
were recouped but the Dean had no idea
at the time that they would be recouped
but he did it because we know was
himself a political refugee secondly it
was a fine moment for law firms the
Simpson Thacher Law Firm which took on
the case pro bono saw it through to the
very end Joe tringali one of the finest
trial lawyers we've met made an enormous
effort got his own partner Cyrus Vance
former Secretary of State a yale law
school graduate involved they also paid
out about $250,000 of their own firm
fees which fortunately then were also
recouped at the Supreme Court stage
dozens of law firms participated in pro
bono efforts and this became a matter
that joined Republicans and Democrats
Mike McConnell a judge on the Tenth
Circuit now who's a frequently mentioned
as the Supreme Court nominee filed a
brief in support of the Haitian position
and it turned out later that the
principles of the case carried through
to representation of Cuban refugees on
Guantanamo and some of the principles
have carried through not to cases
involving the rights of
al Qaeda and other detainees on
Guantanamo third is a fine moment for
article three at least with regard to
judge Johnson who demonstrated the role
of the judge in public law litigation it
was a fine moment for clinical law
because yeah Law School specializes in
live client work you actually represent
real clients and it ended up having a
life-changing effect on many of the
people involved in the case let me
mention this five students who work on
the case went on to become clerks at the
US supreme court even though none of
them went to class so the last part of
the litigation had they been worried
about their class rank had they been
worried about their future job prospects
they might not have done it but this is
one reason that Yale Law School has for
example stood up for the rights of
Japanese internees in the 40s for
implementing Brown versus the Board in
the 60s for the Solomon amendment
challenging the Solomon amendment today
and then I think the final point goes to
what Mike said how do you live your life
as a lawyer it's about finding your
passions and following your passions and
there's nothing like what Brett Dignam
said in your first introductions lecture
client-centered work to make you feel
that it's real for me the moment that
made it most real was when a military
aircraft landed at laguardia airport
carrying 300 haitians they were there
for one reason only a court order issued
by Judge johnson which was the result of
a lawsuit that we brought had we not
brought the suit had he not been there
they would not have landed and when they
landed one of the haitians was going
through an immigration check and he came
to me and he said they have my name
wrong he was showing me he had a
bracelet on his arm it's like a bar code
he said my name is is wrong
and I said what's your name and he had
on a piece of paper a different spelling
of the name and he showed me the piece
of paper and he said this is my name and
at first I said okay we'll go back and
change it and then I realized we
couldn't why couldn't we because the
court order covered all the individuals
with their names as spelled in the court
order which were the names that were
given us originally by the Justice
Department if we spelled this name
correctly he would have no legal rights
and no entitlement to be in the United
States and I said to him well this is
your Ellis Island that's your name now
don't change it or you'll get kicked out
of the country and you stop for a second
he said well then that's my name a
number of years later I was invited to a
high school graduation in mattapan which
is near Boston a number of the 10 to 12
year old kids were on Guantanamo who
came out in that shipment we're
graduating from high school they were
wearing their baseball caps backwards
and baggy pants and they kind of walked
across the stage like this and they got
their diplomas and I thought to myself
maybe one of these days one of those
kids will be Dean of yale law school
because of these efforts that we made
why don't we take any questions that
people might have you must go to the
microphones to continue so it can be
heard on the tape or if others I just
want to have other closing thoughts who
are welcome to but if you have any
questions please approach the microphone
you
really enjoyed the presentation so far I
guess I'd like you if you guys could
talk a little bit more about some of the
public or political or media type
actions that went into supporting the
case as well you touched a little bit on
that but if maybe you could just talk a
little bit more about that appreciate
sure well as I indicated there was a lot
of local sort of low level work here in
New York City and then occasional
celebrity appearances the local work
included we began a weekly picket at the
I NS facility where we go Mel Annette
and then silly as success the second
person let out were detained we act up
members began dogging Clinton around the
country and waiting in rope lines to
shake his hand for instance and then
holding onto his hand and not letting go
and saying why aren't you letting the
Haitians out of Guantanamo what's going
on we worked with local media eventually
Anna Quindlen who is a columnist at the
time for the New York Times wrote two
columns about Celia success one of the
first two people let out a lot of a lot
of the initial work involved in fact
trying to bring together Haitian
activists and AIDS or HIV activists the
latter of whom were almost all white at
least in the New York City organizations
and I can remember sitting in churches
in Brooklyn with representatives of a
bunch of Haitian groups and act up and a
few other HIV in age groups and I'll
just share this one moment because it's
sort of what once we resolved it we were
able to launch the advocacy really
around the country the Haitian groups
were so suspicious of the US government
Haitian ethnicity have been labeled a
risk factor by CDC for HIV not very long
before just the fact of being Haitian
was a risk factor according to CDC which
had outraged the tiny and not very
politically powerful Haitian community
in this country and others and CDC had
eventually changed that but Haitians
were very very suspicious
so the government attempting to label
all people from Haiti is having AIDS and
they denied they kept saying no we don't
believe it just because US government
says the people on Guantanamo of HIV we
don't believe it's true I swear I've
been there I've been there with medical
personnel who reviewed the medical files
I you know at least some people do have
it and no we're not willing to get
involved in any public advocacy that
will say people at Guantanamo with HIV
should be letting because we don't think
they have HIV the act up folks
immediately reacted to the implicit
suggestion that people with HIV or AIDS
were somehow less deserving of support
and became very sort of ended binged
ignant how dare you suggest you know so
what if they do have HIV or AIDS you
know that's why we're here and it took a
little while to find common ground but
once that happened it just kind of took
off locally and nationally that I'll let
Lisa talk about the Jesse and some of
that stuff which came in other ways well
one of the one of the challenges was
getting what was happening in Guantanamo
into the national consciousness and that
was first of all we had to make a
strategic decision whether or not to
highlight and focus on the fact that our
clients were HIV positive obviously
there was a downside to doing that and
that was to raise the level of
apprehension in the public and also to
increase the pressure on the government
to stop folks from coming in and so by
by making the decision to highlight the
fact that our clients were HIV positive
we had to gamble that we could mobilize
greater forces on the on the positive
side then would be mobilized against us
and we had to make sure that that was
true and wet once we had made that
decision there was a freelance reporter
named dan Coughlin who wrote a really
wonderful piece about what was happening
at Guantanamo for a fairly small
publication and that's sort of getting
noticed by other more mainstream
journalists and ultimately reporters
from the New York Times from the Miami
Herald from the Boston Globe and other
newspapers went to Guantanamo there was
even litigation that
helped with to require the government to
allow journalists to go to Guantanamo
and and that helped the I mean that
there was a point at which really
everything was going on there was but
when we went to Guantanamo to convey the
offer the settlement offer and came back
to Brooklyn there was a tour organized
for Haitian community groups for one of
the doctors one of the interpreters
myself on the law students to talk about
what we had seen a video was made of
that of one of those talks and that
video I mean thousands of copies were
made they were sent everywhere around
the country in support of this rolling
hunger strike that Mike alluded to the
refugees were on hunger strike when
Jesse Jackson went to Guantanamo I mean
he didn't just go right he Jackson up
until this point had never publicly
identified himself with any AIDS or HIV
related issue and in fact he was talking
about the plight of the Haitians who
were accused of being hiv-positive
ultimately he he went to went on among
he embraced folks there he said you
don't you know you can start eating now
I am going to go on hunger strike I'm
going to join your hunger strike and it
then became our job to mobilize others
to take that up and so Yale Law Students
as Mike said were in camped in the main
hallway in a makeshift cage with barbed
wire refusing food for a week they then
passed on that hunger strike to Harvard
Law School drove up to Harvard with all
the the pieces of the makeshift camp
that was taken over by Harvard and
ultimately I think over 50 different
schools I had student groups that took
over the hunger strike around the
country so that it could be sustained
over a period of months we would have
conference calls nationally where
student leaders from each of those
schools who were about to strike or had
had not yet done it yet said you know
what else can we do and the answer was
get your parents to write to the White
House and say that their kid is not
eating because you won't let those
refugees at camp and they did that
there was just a massive massive
grassroots mobilization that at the
beginning looked impossible because of
the contradictions embodied by our
client situation we ultimately were able
to make those contradictions work for us
and I think it's important to realize
that there is always opportunity in what
looks like adversity I won't belabor the
point but I want to emphasize that in
many important ways we ended up taking
our cues from our clients in the summer
of 92 there was a kind of a revolt in
the camps that's detailed in the books
which we learned about and pitch to the
Washington Post which wrote and one of
the first important mainstream stories
about it that was our clients activism
that prompted the post story by Lynn
Duke on my second trip to Vaughn tata
motors december of 92 so still predating
the hunger strikes the refugees wrote a
letter to many members of Congress
modeled on Martin Luther King's letter
from a Birmingham jail in which they
described their conditions very
eloquently and invited congressmen and
senators and so forth to come visit them
in their jail and we then carried it out
and delivered it and actually Claiborne
Pell who was then chair of the Senate
Foreign Relations Committee I think
partially in response that letter made
it quiet trip down there in the next
spring then they started the hunger
strike in February and that's really
what launched a lot up here but in many
ways it was their revolt their letter
their hunger strike that prompted our
advocacy here Casey I believe that
there's still an HIV exclusion rule at
least with regards to the issuance of
travel visas and I was wondering what
the current status of HIV exclusion is
with the asylum process and other
aspects of immigration policy you're
exposing my limitations as a so called
immigration expert it's still on the
books it was not repealed in any way but
it's always been right it's but it's
always been the case that there's been
discretionary ways around it and that's
what happened in our case and though it
remains a sort of important target
of immigrant rights advocates it's not
one that's sort of seen as achievable
through litigation right now bush line
let's let judge Johnson and Brandt then
have the last word Charlie it was an
interesting first big case for me as I
said before there are many issues in the
case that I learned about had never had
a TR 0 before I dealt with the
constitutional issues I was fortunate
enough to have a great law clerk twanna
Davis we discussed these saying we
walked late at night if that's any
consolation to you I was amazed to find
out how powerful some bureaucrats can be
and and the impact they have on the
lives of people we don't even know about
I recall that some of the people in
Guantanamo were so sick that the
American doctor said that they should
come to the United States to be treated
but bureaucrats in the Immigration
Department said no they could not come
that is powerful and nobody knew
anything about that and I said as long
as I have the case of bureaucrats not
gonna tell me what to do I'll tell them
what to do that I don't get headaches
out your headaches
I guess I want to make two points the
first is you've probably got in the
sense that this is an incredibly complex
set of cases there were two cases at and
and a number of Appeals my goal in
writing this book was not write a long
policy study or an in-depth doctrinal
analysis it was to write a book that
would be accessible to everybody it is
driven by plot and character you'll get
to know a lot about professor Co a lot
about Mike wish me about judge Johnson
about Lisa du Gard I basically set out
with the following a goal in mind I
wanted everybody in this law school to
find a book like this interesting it
didn't matter whether it was a law
student a law professor a secretary or
somebody who worked in construction
connected to the law school they should
all want to read the book they should
all care about and be excited by it or I
didn't do my job the second thing has to
do with what happened to the 300 people
on Guantanamo and I have two points to
make about that the first one is about
HIV exclusion we've had this right
federal regulation on the books for a
long time but we rarely enforce it
millions of people enter this country
legally every year we don't test them
for HIV and have even one half of one
percent of them are hiv-positive then
tens of thousands of people come in here
legally every year who have this
condition but the federal government
chose to focus just on this small group
of people these 300 people who are
democracy activists fleeing from a
brutal dictator in our own backyard why
apply it just to them why apply it just
to them well it certainly can't be
because of medical costs first as my
coition he told you we settled these
people without cost to the government I
should say that when i say we i mean the
folks who were involved in the case
second this this country allows in
people with heart conditions or kidney
conditions that cost every bit as much
as treating someone with a
in in the later stages of the of that of
that condition and and and I think that
um maybe the better way to look at the
group on Guantanamo is not to say ah you
know what bad things are going to happen
when they come in here but what
contributions might they make because
this is a country of refugees and
immigrants and everyone who comes here
ends up making a contribution and the
people who made it in thanks to the
order by Judge sterling Johnson well
today some of the kids there who are old
enough are now in college and planning
on careers there are taxicab drivers
there are construction workers there are
caterers there are musicians and let me
tell you last and most importantly about
Yvonne Pascal she is alive today and
doing quite well she works a full-time
job she pays for her own health care and
her older son is serving in the United
States Marines and just came back from
Iraq and that's the way I want to leave
it thank you